allez louis à toi tu me fais une passe à
tokyo
soit qui montre qu'un but c'est bientôt
la fin du match
s'est fini le match est terminé dit les
enfants s'arrêtent parce que sans ça on
va tous est épuisé un ange une idée on
va les voir julie elle aura certainement
une histoire affronter sanou reposera
bien oui
ils ont gelé
le match est déjà perdue est terminé
mais on est mort de fatigue et quelques
à gagner personne on a fait match nul
mais ça n'a pas été facile et ben bravo
tout le monde elle d'angély j'ai pensé
que tu pourrais peut-être nous raconter
une histoire pendant qu'on se repose à
ben justement je viens de lire un poème
de jacques prévert voulait que vous ayez
tchatche verbe évidemment les eaux
s'installe dans l'ère des enfants et on
écoute julie
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un poème de jacques prévert
qui s'appelle pages d'écriture 2 et 2
caps ktk tuit-tuit t8 française répéter
ville m 2 et 2,4 après 4,8 eut été huit
françaises
voilà l'oiseau lyre qui passe dans le
ciel
l'enfant voit l'enfant l'entente
l'enfant l'appel sous moi jouent avec
moi oiseaux
alors le réseau des sens et joue avec
l'enfant 2 et 2,4 répétées du lemaitre
et l'enfant joue l'oiseau joue avec lui
4 et 4 8 8 et 8 concèze et sazy 16
qu'est ce qu'ils font une faune rien
savez fès et surtout pas 32 de toute
façon elles s'en vont
et l'enfant à cacher l'oiseau dans son
pupitre
et tous les enfants en temps de sa
chanson et tous les enfants autant de la
musique il où tu habites à leur tour
savon et 4 à 4 et 2 à 2 à leur tour
fiche le camp et à la 120e également et
l'oiseau lyre joue et l'enfant chante et
le professeur cris quand vous aurez fini
de faire le pitre mais tous les autres
enfants écoutent la musique
et les murs de la classe s'écroule
tranquillement et les vitres
redeviennent sable lancre redevient au
le pupitre on redevienne arbres la craie
redevient phalange elle ne porte plus
redevient moisson
bravo bravo julie c'est vraiment un très
beau poème et tu l'a très bien dit n'en
fait pas rire a beaucoup du mur
qu'est-ce qu'il ya casimir ce poème ne
peut pas le poème est très beau c'est
vrai mais la façon de le raconter et
parfaitement des mots des deux modèles
mais moi je vais pas une autre façon de
raconter une histoire si en la jouant
commenté à après je vais vous jouez des
histoires et et vous devrez deviner quel
est le personnage ou carrefour midas et
sans dieu c'est une bonne idée d'accord
mais il faut d'abord que j'appelle ma
malle magique
magic bien ici
[Applaudissements]
encore
hop
[Musique]
dont casimir tamales magique est de plus
en plus magique je l'avais jamais vu
verte je lui ai apporté quelques petits
perfectionnement technique
elle marque beaucoup mieux
mais elle parle aussi oui enfin ça c'est
plutôt un inconvénient
bon alors vous êtes prêt on peut
commencer ah oui on est prêt bon vous
avez bien compris les enfants
daisy mire va nous montrer des
personnages et des histoires différentes
et on va chercher ce que c'est à chaque
fois
et vous si chez vous à vous cherchez et
vous essayez de trouver les premiers
bons alors attention première histoire
bonjour mercato je vous ai apporté une
galère et un petit pot de beurre
alors les enfants
le petit chaperon rouge
s à casimir ouais vous pouvez retrouver
tout de suite je vais trouver julie ma
fille et je pense que chez eux les
enfants avaient tout de suite trouvé
aussi qui nous fait autre chose autre
chose alors allez deuxième histoire
moi monsieur si j'avais un tel mais il
faudrait sur le champ que je me lance
plus tard ça
c'est bon pique c'est un cap c'est un
rack qu'en dit jean roch c'est une
péninsule
vos bras lors vous trouvez chercher chez
vous qui s est il se mettre à la raison
soro est ce que ces euros à 12 euros
monsieur dont on nous sort on
appartenait à qui un grenat comme ça je
vais mettre à la raison voilà enfin la
marque kia
on peut me chaut cyrano de bergerac
voilà cyrano de bergerac d'edmond
rostand vous avez trouvé bon casimir qui
nous ont fait un troisième histoire
allez-y ma chère moi j'ai tout mon temps
je ne parte pas bêtement ma maison sur
mon dos aux alors alors
et acquis par le lièvre
très bien mais se loge à la tortue
lièvre et la tortue et qui a écrit cette
fable vous ne savez pas c'est monsieur
jean de la fontaine
je suis certain que tous nos amis chez
eux retrouvez bonvin casimir qui nous
fait un autre personne alors qu'il te
plaît une autre histoire
haha
attention bandits ne bougeait pas
sergent garcia je vous ravit la
moustache d'un coup d'épée
[Musique]
alors qui est ce personnage
zorro on l'a vu qualifier tous vous êtes
vieux euros mais ces cases in here je
suis euros et un clip à nouveau au
sergent garcia cette crapule là vous
aviez trouvé les cheveux parfait casimir
grâce à sa malle magique nous fait un
autre personnage allait les énergies
elle n'oublie pas que tu dois être
rentré à ben le douzième coup de minuit
sinon une carence en deviendra
citrouilles ont été chauds vos deux
viendront souri
aux alors en tout cas casimir quelle
élégance et fille c'est la vie fait il a
fait de cendrillon et 100 m c'est ça
l'agent qui fait c'est la gentille parce
que y'en a une qui très méchante de
feuilles dans cendrillon et bien bravo
quasiment un autre personnage
attention
[Musique]
dans la mare casimir mon vieux on sort
de là mais qu'est-ce-qui paris
15eme mot est dit dans casimir je
croyais que tu as mal magic était très
perfectionné
leurs points d'accord quand
on arrive
c'est pourquoi faire tout ça tout mauger
et par qui baissent partout nous par les
enfants par toi par françois par mois
par tous ceux qui en voudront mais alors
c'est une fête type qui veut elle qu'est
ce que tu fais rien du tout comment ça
je ne sais rien du tout mais c'est
impossible
pourquoi mais quand on organise une fête
c'est pour fêter quelque chose et que tu
vas comprendre thiam dit surpris - ouais
et ben moi je trouve que c'est très
important les surprises dans la vie par
exemple offrir un beau bouquet de fleurs
à sa maman sans attendre le jour de son
anniversaire c'est une vraie surprise je
trouve ça beaucoup plus gentil c'est
bien vrai et bien aujourd'hui je fais
une fête comme ça sans raison et bien
moi j'ai une idée
laquelle et bien si pour cette fête on
faisait une danse oui alors mais alors
si aujourd'hui on improvise un haut fait
ce qu'on veut d'accord mais avec
nouvelles musiques entendues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
mais
d
m
[Musique]
ted
pas
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
elle est où
tous
[Musique]
vous oh
or à julie je crois que ça suffit comme
ça c'était pas mal à notre d'or ce
là là on s'est bien amusé ça m'a donné
très fin si on mangeait quelque chose
n'avons pas encore il faut attendre que
tout le monde scolaire or c'est dommage
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette boîte et
ne tarte aux prunes une tarte aux prunes
j'adore la tarte aux prunes mais
attention casimir il n'y a ni anchois ni
cornichons nice aussi son rap et oui
mais ça ne fait rien la tarte aux prunes
est le seul gâteau que j'adore sans rien
ajouter
alors est-ce qu'on peut l'ouvrir non non
non je ne la sortirait que lorsque tout
le reste aura été mangés au mais moi je
préfère la tarte aux prunes beaucoup de
casimir fait pas tant d'enfants gâtés
regarde tout ce qui est beau a mouché
oui mais commence par la jettera pas
enfin bon je fais chauffer les autres et
je te permets en attendant de commencer
bon
[Musique]
voyons voyons
saucisson
julie nous a préparé de bons souvenirs
est déjà là d'ailleurs révélé
que ce qui s'est passé tu m'avais
demandé de commencer on voit que
l'injure casimir tu as tout manger et
nous reste plus qu une rondelle de
saucisson par personne casimir c'est
vraiment pas très gentil pour les autres
ça mais j'avais tellement faim
c'est peu heureusement que j'ai gardées
en réserve la tarte aux prunes notamment
florent des
contrôles
médicaux casimir j'ai compris
tu as tout manger pour être sûrs que
nous entamerions les parts ont fait de
suite tu as raison julie mais là je suis
bien pu mieux pourquoi parce que j'ai
tellement mangé beaucoup je n'ai plus
faim du tout tient ce
week end
[Musique]